so my dad when I was a kid he broke the
world record for the longest distance
traveled in 24 hours by human power his
bike was called critical power the logo
was a skull so that's why I have three
skulls tattooed no wonder you're a
[ __ ] beast when it comes to running
swimming well that's like part of the
reason why it like it makes me happy
because I feel like it's kind of in my
blood yeah it's like I was raised around
it and seeing it so much so now it feels
kind of like I was meant to do it yeah
so instilled in your DNA so you're able
to do it yeah have you heard about that
like people who if you're pregnant with
a baby and you're scared of water your
baby is most likely gonna also have that
same really yeah yeah huh that's
interesting
you never heard about it no like so the
reason why I'm such a good cook
it's because it was distilled in My DNA
from my Father Brown Yeah from Brown
Town Brown town
can I say that yeah you can say it okay
how would you say it okay good
you gave the when did you move from
Canada again the brown path
but I actually have been thinking about
that because I think a lot of people
actually get discouraged when they're
like oh it was like he's built to do
this it's like in his genetics and I
don't think that's actually true like
neither of my parents were athletes when
I was born right both of them became
athletes just because they like my dad
was never an endurance athlete he was
like he's like like to lift weights and
it wasn't very healthy he had asthma and
you know never ate right or anything
like that and then made a decision in
his 30s where he wanted to like you know
pursue these crazy endurance yeah
um Athletics and through that like
became super healthy cured himself of
asthma
and like became this Beast athlete but
it's not like he was born to do it he
just decided to do it yeah it's like and
I feel like that's people can find
inspiration on that because it's like no
literally anyone can do this stuff you
just have to like train up to it have
you always been sick at [ __ ]
athleticism no I mean like I I was
always I was never I was always like a
good good at being an athlete but I was
never a gifted athlete yeah like with
diving I was never I was never the one
that like everyone looked at like oh
that kid's gonna be incredible yeah I
just worked really hard so I was able to
get to a place that was like respectable
yeah but I was never gonna be the top
because I wasn't like just naturally
gifted enough it's the same thing with
Endurance Sports I'm not like you know
I'm not not the guy that's going to
start running 6 30 miles like just
because I'm built for it or not you know
you can't run 6 30 miles no I mean like
yeah I can but yeah because I've trained
up to it damn you're sick I used to be
sick of running too yeah you did right
yeah he said I ran the marathon when I
was 13 years old you ran a marathon when
you were 13. I mean it was it wasn't
good wait it's got to be bad for your
like bones oh it was most definitely
don't doctors say don't do that when
you're young like you're not you're not
supposed to like lift weights until
you're like 16 or something yeah no one
of them a [ __ ]
okay why did you run a marathon when
you're 13. there was a program it was
actually my cousins were chasing after
me
it was a cool program uh in middle
school called students from LA and
essentially it's like they take young
kids and they train them to run the
marathon and so like I'm in I'm 13 years
old is this this is legal yeah it feels
like it should be illegal no it was
weird too because they bet money and
yeah no it was it was it was tight it
was tight basically you go like every
day you would run after school and then
oh there it is
look there's me actually
that's how skinny I was
and dude there'd be weekends when I'm
[ __ ] running like 18 miles I'm like
as of 13. as a 13 year old okay I need
to know if this is actually safe or not
probably not but I did like it because I
ended up going to high school running
all my four years right so how fast were
you dude I [ __ ] [ __ ] I had it all man
did you had it all man [ __ ] I ran the
mile at 4 30.
my sophomore year holy [ __ ] like one of
the last races wow good for you physical
Ed should children run marathons
with proper training and planning the
Marathon distance can be safe for
certain highly motivated children
[Laughter]
damn I just feel like there's something
like as your body is developing I feel
like that's a crucial stage no it
definitely [ __ ] with like that's why
you're not supposed to like have
caffeine and stuff right as a kid
because yeah anyways I mean that's still
[ __ ] impressive yeah it was sick it
was sick I'm I'm very thankful for it
because then I learned how to Pace
myself because that's what all running
really is yeah like you're pacing you're
just holding out energy till the end
yeah you're breathing doing breathing
[ __ ] techniques and I was able to
learn all that when I was 13. I think I
only did it was like seven hours it took
me to finish the marathon it was a long
time okay yeah I mean it's a [ __ ] time
I was 13 dude yeah I know but it still
sucks what did you run it at uh my
fastest marathon was I just looked it up
yesterday it was 3 43. damn which is
pretty good that's from that was my very
first one too yeah I trained my ass off
for that and then I just completely lost
it afterwards why what happened like I
just like stopped you're training now
again right I am yeah I'm trying to so
I'm doing a marathon in seven weeks nice
and uh like I'm getting I'm training
super hard right now just like because I
got this Iron Man coach so he's giving
me a ton of workouts I'm doing two a
days basically like every day now so
like I wanna I wanna try and I'm getting
faster in my running I can see it yeah
and just feel it like it's like you know
running at a eight and a half
minute mile Pace used to be really hard
for me now it's like a 200 miles so I
think I'm gonna try and go for like sub
330.
on this marathon and try and see if like
eventually maybe down the road I could
shoot for three does Kelsey go two
watches she's gonna go yeah I think
she's gonna go it might be your dad's
birthday so I gotta make a sign yeah
what would it say I'm in love with the
Coco
you didn't like the shirt
it was no I love the shirt man that was
that's why you're invited to my wedding
yes